je préfère partir en alsace puisque nous
restons dans le domaine de la
gastronomie avec à partir d'aujourd'hui
une série de reportages sur des repas de
fête élaboré par de grands chefs
ce matin nous nous rendons donc en
alsace dans les cuisines d'emile jung
cuisinier du célèbre restaurant le
crocodile à strasbourg un trois étoiles
au guide michelin
voici un repas pour 6 personnes que vous
pourrez faire vous même pour une somme
inférieure à 1000 francs
une recette qui allie tradition et
originalité j'en espérais vincent
maillard t'enlever l'esprit bien aiguisé
le meilleur moment pour faire ses
courses
à cette heure les vitrines regorgent de
tout ce que l'alsace compte de
spécialités objectif ou d'un nombre
était à bout d'un de plus ses chances
direction le marché de gros à strasbourg
on l'appelle le marché gare un petit
paradis pour grands chefs comme pour les
particuliers
on y trouve tout ce qu'il faut pour
préparer un merveilleux repas de fête
qu'est ce que vous avez prévu de faire
comme endroit pour débuter un poisson à
poissons d'ici un poisson rassemble avec
quelques écarts des crèmes de persil
avons ensuite eu loi
elle me voir aussi au monde bien aux
yeux rouges il a renié avec la
choucroute et des galettes de pommes de
terre ou d'un noir et une connotation
vallée rhénane alsace et ensuite pour
terminer tout le monde aime le chocolat
on va faire un dessert au chocolat
maintenant à chercher le poisson le menu
dessinée il faut choisir les ingrédients
premier constat premier conseil alors ça
c'est regarder et des magnifiques la nef
surtout non seulement il est bold et
sanguinolent il est super frais mais il
est ferme
le produit il a plus de talent que
l'homme c'est le produit qui a du temps
devant nous cuisiner on leur donne juste
un peu d'esprit à une touche quoi retour
aux crocodiles
après une petite mise en bouche au
boulou compter trois bonnes heures de
travail pour toujours goûter toujours
goûter
très important première étape la
préparation du centre enfourner sur un
lit d'échalotes et de champignons coupés
à que s'il est trop long ou pas hésité à
sa marque détails essentiels avoir le
geste généreux au parloir peur de mekla
bouteille est ce que comme c'est cuit
c'est parti au delà
moi je devais parler de ma cuisine et
les très lisible on la reconnaît
on sait ce qu'on mange on a du plaisir
c'est ça l'essentiel n'est pas
intellectuel et tout de suite
elle est en prise directe je dirais
passons au plat de résistance loire
outils pour bien l'accueillir
le truc du chef pour partir nous permet
pas mettre de grèce parce que c'est très
grave
on va mettre de l'eau avec deux douches
d'eau la 9e mais au cours une heure et
demie au four juste le temps de cuisiner
les choucroutes voilà alors réparti la
chaux côte un petit morceau de lard et
en salle
ça ce niveau là qu'il faut ça l'est
aussi daniel lebègue lauriers et une
heure à feu doux il reste à préparer les
galettes de pommes de terre au four et
au boudin noir
la seule difficulté encore de ce plat
familial mais original à déconseiller
toutefois aux inconditionnels des menus
alléger
et voilà le travail
un repas de fin d'année typiquement
alsacien élaborés à partir de produits
rigoureusement régionaux loi la
choucroute le sandre avec escargots et
crème de persil l'ensemble mêle
habilement les astuces du grand chef et
la tradition culinaire alsacienne
quoiqu'elle se perdent un peu dans le
temps on fêtait pas noël comme
aujourd'hui un mets donc c'était plus
simple on jaune est normalement la
veille de noël et c'était le lendemain
qu'on fait
mais aujourd'hui comme la famille est
éclatée déstructuré ou profitent
effectivement de noël pour se retrouver
se trouver la paix riesling pour
accompagner le sandre pinot noir
d'alsace évidemment pour le plat
principal et le dessert dont tous à une
charlotte au chocolat couverte de
chantilly des étoiles en langues des
étoiles juste avant l'embrasement des
papilles